[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE COLEMAN: Hi.
I'm Mike Coleman, a developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
And in this video,
I want to show you
how you can use
Migrate for Anthos
to migrate IBM WebSphere
applications to containers
in just a few clicks.
We'll start by looking at
the system requirements.
Then I'll provide
a quick overview
of the migration process.
Then we'll jump into
an actual migration.
Now, this video is part of a
series on Migrate for Anthos.
So if you haven't checked
out those first videos
in the series, you might want
to go back and watch those,
as this video builds on them.
You can find the link
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we get started, I wanted
to clarify that in this video,
I'm discussing the migration
of traditional IBM WebSphere
Application Server and IBM
WebSphere Application Server
Network Deployment applications
rather than IBM WebSphere
Liberty apps.
Keep that distinction
in mind when
you hear me say WebSphere
Application Server.
Migrate for Anthos lets you
modernize app workloads running
in WebSphere Application
Servers by converting them
to application containers.
You can then deploy
the app containers
to GKE or Anthos
clusters on Google Cloud,
Anthos clusters on VMware,
and Anthos clusters on AWS.
A WebSphere Application Server
VM can contain multiple apps.
Migrate for Anthos helps you
automate the modernization
of WebSphere
Application Server apps
to containers by discovering
deployed apps in the source VM
and automatically
suggesting the configuration
for the modernization.
With Migrate for Anthos,
you migrate each app
to its own container.
This allows you to test and
deploy the migrated apps
individually rather than
having to test and deploy
multiple apps together.
Regardless of whether
or not your source
apps were running WebSphere
Application Server or WebSphere
Application Server
Network Deployment,
the resulting container image
will be the official IBM
WebSphere Application Server
traditional container image.
And for those of you wondering,
the original responsibilities
of network deployment--
clustering, scheduling,
version roll-outs, request
routing, et cetera--
will now be offloaded
to Kubernetes.
Migrate for Anthos supports
the migration of apps
hosted on the following versions
of IBM WebSphere Application
Server--
WebSphere Application
Server traditional 8.5.5.x
and WebSphere Application
Server traditional 9.0.5.x.
Migrate for Anthos
extracts two types
of configurations from the VM--
the configuration
for each application
and the configuration
of the target profile,
which defines the runtime
environment of a WebSphere
Application Server, including
ports, the Java virtual machine
settings, et cetera.
The Migrate for Anthos
software automates the use
of the IBM WebSphere Application
Server Migration Toolkit
for application binaries to
discover, assess, and generate
migration reports, as well as
creating configuration scripts.
Before you can
start a migration,
you must upload the toolkit
to a Google Cloud Storage
bucket in your account.
Check the documentation for more
information on this procedure.
When migrating WebSphere
Application Server apps,
the processing cluster can be
deployed on Google Kubernetes
Engine or an Anthos cluster on
Google Cloud, VMware, or AWS.
Regardless of where
the cluster runs,
it must use a Cloud
Storage bucket
as the repository for the
resulting migration artifacts.
For more information on
creating a processing cluster,
check out the first
video in this series.
You can find a link in
the description below.
And be sure to read the docs
to get the full details on all
the system requirements.
With the prerequisites
out of the way,
let's take a look at the
general migration flow.
First, you're going to add
a migration source, which
represents the source
platform from which
you will be migrating.
Then you're going to
create the migration.
And that specifies the VM you're
actually going to migrate.
You'll edit your
migration plan, including
selecting the WebSphere
Application Server
app that you want to migrate.
And you should migrate one
WebSphere Application Server
app per migration.
Then you're going to actually
perform the migration
to generate the app
container artifacts,
and then review those
artifacts in preparation
for building the
deployable app image.
Now, use the migrated
artifacts to build
a container for
your migrated app,
and then deploy your migrated
app to your target cluster.
Finally, test the migrated app
and validate the migration.
Note that if your source
VM has multiple apps,
you're going to need
to repeat steps 3
through 7 for each application
you wish to migrate.
Also, you may have noticed if
you've watched previous videos,
there's not an explicit step
to assess the application using
the Discovery tool.
That's because the
assessment happens
when you run the migration.
All right.
Let's go ahead and jump
into an actual migration.
We're going to take a
source VM and extract
a single application
from that VM,
then deploy it to a GKE cluster
following the basic flow
that I just outlined.
As you can see in
the Cloud Console,
I've actually already created
my migration processing cluster
and my migration source.
I've also gone in and I've
stopped my WebSphere VM.
With those things
out of the way,
I'm all ready to start by
creating the actual migration.
And to do that, I'll
move into the Cloud Shell
and issue the migctl
create command.
Most of these parameters
are pretty straightforward,
but I wanted to point out
this app-type property
at the bottom.
That's where we specify that
we're actually migrating
a WebSphere application.
Creating a migration is
going to take a few minutes,
so I'm going to pause
the video, and I'll
come back when it's done.
With the migration
assessment completed,
I wanted to show you the
application discovery
report that was generated.
It's stored up in a
Cloud Storage bucket.
So let's navigate to the
actual report and load it up.
Now, I'm not going to go
through the report in detail.
I just want you to know
that it's available to you,
and that it will give you
a bunch of information
on the applications
that were scanned.
Let's move back
into Cloud Shell.
And I need to download and
edit my migration.yaml.
So I'll use migctl
get migration.
And then I'm going to go
in and edit that file,
and here are these
path variables.
Now, they represent
the applications
that were found during
the scanning process.
And I only need one of them.
You only migrate one
application at a time.
So I'm going to delete this
query.ear path location here.
And then the other
thing I want to do
is I want to go down
to the default app name
and change that from
WebSphere to something else.
So I'll make that change here.
And I'll actually
make the change
for the name of the Docker
image that's created as well.
We use migctl to upload
our updated migration plan,
so that when we execute the
migration in the next step,
these new settings are used.
And so let's go
ahead and do that.
I'll clear the screen.
And then I'm going to use migctl
to execute the migration plan
and generate my
migration artifacts.
This will take a few minutes,
so I'm going to pause the video,
and I'll rejoin when it's done.
migctl is finished, so let's go
ahead and grab those artifacts
using migctl get-artifacts.
I will list out the
directories so you
can see which was created.
We've got a Docker file,
our application's .ear file,
and this wsadmin.py file.
This is where a bunch of
settings for your application
will be held.
And you may need to edit that,
depending on your application.
Finally, there's a
build script that
automates the creation
of our Docker image
and uploads it to the
Container Registry.
I'll go ahead and
execute our build script.
The build file takes
several minutes to run.
I've sped up the video
so you can see what's
happening in the background.
It's going to pull
the base Docker image.
Then it runs through the
configuration of the WebSphere
server, including copying
in the application.
And then finally, it pushes that
completed container image up
into the Registry.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
edit the deployment.yaml file,
which by default provides
a headless cluster IP
service which is only accessible
from within the cluster.
I'm going to change that
to type LoadBalancer
so we can access our
service externally.
All that's left to do
now is to actually deploy
the application, and we'll do
that using kubectl apply -f
deployment_spec.yaml.
That's going to
deploy that deployment
spec we just looked at.
So we're going to
create a service,
we're going to
create a deployment,
and then we can check
the status of those
by using kubectl get pods
and kubectl get service.
Now, from the service, we can
grab the external IP address
here and see that our
application, a movie
rental service, is up and
running in our browser.
And that's all it
takes to migrate
a WebSphere application
running in a VM
to running on Kubernetes.
There you have it.
We've successfully
migrated an application
from WebSphere Application
Server running in a VM
to a container running on GKE.
If you haven't already, be
sure to like and subscribe,
as we'll be adding additional
videos to the series.
And feel free to check
out Migrate for Anthos
up on Google Cloud today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]